do you have multiple kubernetes clusters
across different cards and your own data
centers then you know how challenging it
is to manage them how can you simplify
your multi cluster strategy with Antos
keep watching to find out hi I'm
Priyanka Regalia and welcome to this
episode of anthos 101 where we will
cover the reasons for adopting a multi
cluster strategy and how anthos can help
you manage multiple clusters easily why
would you adopt a multi cluster strategy
well the answer is one of two reasons
your workload needs isolation or you
need compute anywhere let's dive deeper
into isolation by isolation we often
mean both isolation of control plane and
the isolation of data plane the most
obvious reason to leverage multiple
clusters is to separate your prod and
non Tron environments mainly to ensure
the production environment is tightly
controlled and not compromised during
development and testing the second
reason is controlling the blast radius
you may be running the same app across
multiple clusters just to ensure that
the application remains resilient to
failures or changes occurring in the
single cluster the other reason could be
tenant separation you would do this for
a variety of reasons like you've
identified some applications that don't
play well together and want to keep them
separated you're running a mix of
trusted and untrusted code and want
stronger boundaries between them you've
got some really important services that
you want to ensure are always up and
finally you may want to isolate for
security and compliance reasons
now the other dimension to consider when
adopting a multi cluster strategy is the
need to provide compute platform
anywhere and everywhere your
organization deploys applications you
might want to call a caterer kubernetes
instances with existing infrastructure
allowing you to modernize applications
that sit directly near those hard to
move databases and stable services
availability could be another driving
factor running applications across
regions and even clouds can help ensure
your application remains up and running
just
any outages regulatory requirements also
lend themselves to multiple clusters
especially for multinationals with data
residency requirements and we know that
each cloud has differentiated services
that development teams want to use
making developer choice another
important factor now that we know why
you may need to adopt a multi cluster
strategy let's talk about the
operational challenges of maintaining
multiple clusters across clouds and your
own data centers in most organizations
the platform teams are responsible for
developing custom solutions or cobbling
together open source tooling for
practically everything and this leads to
a lot of friction in adopting a multi
cluster strategy managing the lifecycle
of each cluster using different tooling
from different vendors ensuring uniform
access and governance controls across
the cluster getting insights into your
global set of applications enabling
application teams to efficiently deliver
software to all their clusters and
managing traffic to provide redundancy
and to reduce latency this is what we
set out to solve with anta's let's cover
a few of the multi cluster solutions we
have in Antos anthos gke gives your team
a consistent container management
experience and those config management
unifies access policies and provides
governance across multiple clusters and
those service mesh allows you to set and
monitor a Zillow's on your services
secure traffic between services even
across the cluster boundary and ingress
for anthos allows you to load balanced
external traffic to the closest cluster
to your end-users this helps you to
build low latency and high availability
services in multiple GCP regions to make
it easier to take advantage of these
multi cluster features we are
introducing a concept called & Wine's
VIP admirers you can group related
resources like clusters into a single
management domain once resources are
grouped together in an environmentally
managed multi cluster features and
components across all in line
this simple yet powerful concept allows
you to up level
your management from cluster by cluster
to group of clusters for example within
minds you can now apply and enforce
common policy and config across all in
line members using anthems config
management create a service mesh over
all members of an in mind using a DOS
service mash and even load balance
external traffic into your gke clusters
using ingress for anthos there you have
it
anthos simplifies the adoption of multi
cluster strategy across clouds and
on-prem with the concept of in wines
going forward all multi cluster features
will be managed within wine so expect
more in this space check out the
environment at is's guide linked below
and get started today
for more anthos content don't forget to
subscribe to follow the entire anthos
101 playlist
[Music]